of course as far as do you think there
is a particular problem with labor and
anti-semitism yes I do and I think there
was at the other big big report the
Shami Chakrabarti did a few years ago
and I think kind of a blind eyes been
turned to this I think I think was a
problem with anti-semitism not just in
my labour party by the way I think there
is a whole narrative around the
israel-palestine conflict where perhaps
people's loyalties towards the
Palestinian side have been allowed
they've been allowed to say things
perhaps way way ahead of what should
have been allowed there are of course
there are other forms of racism around
and sure you know very well yours break
there is a Nationalist Party if I can
put it that way sureness a nation nation
is what are you doing to ensure that you
don't get racist elements joining up
well I as you may remember in UK i
forbade anybody who'd been a member of
extreme organizations like the BNP from
even being members of UK and I'm doing
exactly the same thing with a brexit
party we will be as a party we will be
deeply intolerant on intolerance we talk
of it as a party it's not a party though
is it's it's a business just won a
national election and the fact that it
operates itself yeah through a little
bit I'm saying you don't have a
membership we have registered supporters
you know we run it you're quite right we
have a board of directors that's where
our decisions get made we're still very
young by the way we're just six months
old and we have registered supporters
and we've got about 150 thousand of
those who paid their 25 quid it's pretty
much like being a member and you do vet
members in there in the same way we vet
what we do that our candidates members
we're doing what we can to vet them you
know we've seen things like that was
withdrawn you know your friends that
levy you putting out that we don't want
to be ordered around by a crowd well
yeah I don't think that's racist I think
it's ridiculous to use language like
that I think it may be it's just a
couple of decades out of date
that was all you I mean you do you
defend it I've just said to you as a
couple of decades out of date that is
how you and I would have spoken
just after we left school that was a
language of the days law a language of a
date you know what I mean the language
they was different language evolves it
moves on now what about
what's going on here I mean from the
point of view of the brakes it party
yeah best thing could happen for you
would be no deal all around wouldn't it
well the best thing for us would be to
have Breck set and brakes it means
leaving the single market leaving the
customs union leaving the jurisdiction
of the ECJ and ultimately having a
sensible trade agreement with our
friends in Europe that's what we've
always wanted you know happy with
reciprocity happy with fair exchange but
not to be part of the political
institutions and here's the problem that
okay the back stop gets replaced with
something else but from a DUP
perspective it may feel as bad if
perhaps not even worse than the back
stop but on everything else in terms of
where we go let's just say for
argument's sake this got agreed would it
end the problems of this great breaks it
debate no arguably we've just done the
easy bit the hard bit would be what is
you know what comes over the course of
the next two or three years because
we're gonna be half in half out in this
never-never-land and the real problem is
this to get to any sort of free trade
deal with the EU already the French and
Spanish are saying are war fishing you
know you can't have your territorial
fishing borders back it would appear we
don't know I mean but against that I
mean it is true our fishermen mainly
sell their stuff into the European
because there's an insatiable demand but
that's well there does have to be some
give-and-take doesn't that no because
there is a big difference between
selling or buying and selling goods and
actually having management and control
of what should be yours
similarly with regulator realignment and
if we finish up in a negotiation for the
next two three four years about
regulatory alignment where they won't
give an inch about building on the
existing customs partnership many of us
would say what's the point of let
against that do you want Britain to have
were standards in workers rights worse
than the democracy me no no this is this
is where the argument goes wrong in a
democracy you should debate at general
elections employment legislation
environmental legislation I think we're
perfectly capable of doing it far better
than that it's done any EULA well may be
capable of it but should we do it
because if we yes yes we're going to be
a direct competition were the year
in union undercutting them in that area
might be well that's called competition
it's called being efficient it's the one
thing the year you were terrified of
Angela Merkel laughs yeah but what I'm
saying is do you back that because you
do back single people with no M's if
we're not making our own laws across
across the whole range of issues we're
not an independent country that's what
breaks it's about it's about us being
together there's also a question about
what sort of independent countries and
is it a high environment but we all
decide right we will decide that it we
will actually have general elections
where we start debating this sort of
stuff again which we haven't done for
the last thirty years because all of
those rules have been made here in the
EU and at that point if we get there if
we get that independence and watch upon
the brexit party but we will have
achieved a great historic victory what's
wrong with that and we'll go on will you
go on that well Russia political reform
there are many other things that we're
talking about that people really want to
see post brexit but look we're dealing
here with the biggest political crisis
you know arguably for a couple hundred
years and we want to get this delivered
and if if Boris Johnson comes back with
just a slight amendment to miss his mais
dreadful EU treaty and that's what it is
then I think you'll find support for the
brexit party rising very sharply there
okay so let's be clear if Boris Johnson
does what he's setting out to do he gets
an agreement and he gets Parliament to
endorse it both pretty big if yeah sure
you're saying you won't back off yet
there's a brexit party will run against
the Kurds no because we we're gonna be
stuck in as never-never-land for years
to come
it's the worst of all worlds the worst
of all worlds and if parlance say we're
going to put you back in the box as he
said no I know he keeps trying and the
worst of all worlds would be what if a
referendum amendment passed on and I say
let's not call it a deal let's call it
what it is an EU treaty but if we had
this passed on Saturday with a
referendum amendment I mean that would
be our democracy simply reduce but all
right what do you do just suppose we do
get to a referendum yeah and the choice
is the deal which you don't like yeah
or remaining which you think is even
worse what are you going to do if the
choice is the existing EU treaties or a
new EU treaty I
stay at home I'm gonna have a new way to
your support boat
I won't campaign I have nothing to do
with it whatsoever you cannot I mean
even to have another referendum is wrong
to have one or not put a credible leave
option on the ballot paper would be a
democratic outrage but it might be
binding well that wasn't so why should
it be all this situation you've got us
into we might end up remaining after all
that having why should I you know I want
us it perfectly clear every leading
player on the leaving remains side said
Ally vote means leaving the single
market and leaving the customs union
leaving regulator alignment being in
charge ourself of this legislation and
that's what needs to be delivered and
you're saying this deal isn't that
absolutely not and as far as yourself
I'm just trying to work this out so we
come to this election you're running
against the Conservatives Boris Johnson
mark will be saying presumably I've
taken this out I mean you don't stand
much for child ste well I tell you what
I tell you what III don't think what
Evers agreed tonight is gonna pass on
Saturday anyway so I think that may be
an academic discussion but let me put
this to you if withdrawal agreement for
fails on Saturdays I believe it will I
think then Boris Johnson as Prime
Minister will drop the idea of this new
treaty and there is the possibility of
putting together a leave alliance for
the next general election and all the
numbers and all the projects you're
saying if if he doesn't get a deal it
doesn't get through that's the moment
when breakdown and the Conservatives can
start working together I think I think
there is an opportunity here for a
brexit Alliance to fight the election
that would win a big majority in
parliament so look you know I would much
rather we have an extension and a chance
of a general election that accept this
dreadful new EU Tracy absolutely so
that's the offer to Boris Johnson go for
No Deal and we can talk Turkey I think
in a general election manifesto you know
he can even talk about going for genuine
free trade agreement there
I think getting rid of mr. Barney as
treaty is the really important thing
because I mean as things stand if there
is an agreement and and yang and and you
run all you will do is help the remain
parties well Adam with respect you said
that to me in 2015 you said that
standing 640 odd you kept candidates
would split the conservative vote in
fact we heard the Labour vote in you
keep all those years ago much more in
that election than we have the
Conservatives and now that Labour have
gone for a full-on
second referendum policy there weren't
any five million labour voters that
voted leave so difficult to predict what
the effect of the brexit party would be
in most circumstances